is that prank yes hi you're Frank this
is Jimmy Hoffa the first trailer has
arrived for the upcoming Netflix found
the Irishmen and as it heads toward the
opening slot at the New York Film
Festival people are wondering will this
movie bring Oscar glory to Netflix well
let's talk about it right now on the new
ride tomato show the ketchup where are
you going
go to work so the Martin Scorsese
directed film based on the biography of
Frank the Irishman Sheeran by Charles
Brandt stars Al Pacino as Jimmy Hoffa
and Robert De Niro as his friend and
alleged murderer hitman Frank Sheeran
now it was recently announced that the
Irishman will be the opening night film
of the New York Film Festival on
September 27 which is pretty much where
future Oscar contenders go to kick off
their campaigns the film will later be
released in select theaters and will
also stream on Netflix this fall a
rollout similar to 2018 s Best Picture
nominee Romo so it's clear there's some
high expectations for this movie to
submit Netflix as a major player in
Hollywood you might be demonstrating the
failure to show appreciation but the
journey to get here was not easy for mr.
Scorsese who's been talking about doing
this fashion project as far back as 2008
but with an award-winning crew and cast
that includes Joe Pesci Harvey Keitel
Anna Paquin Bobby Cannavale II Jesse
Plemons and Ray Romano and since
Everybody Loves Raymond and the rest of
the people I just mentioned the Irishman
was initially targeted for a risky 100
million dollar budget but that cost
jumped to nearly 200 million because of
the CGI D aging used in the film so that
the stars could play younger versions of
their characters for part of the movie
and I thought Botox was expensive this
is a trend that has become more popular
lately with actors like samuel l.jackson
and Captain Marvel and Will Smith in the
upcoming Gemini Man which is hilarious
because Will Smith hasn't aged at all
but I digress that hefty price tag
scared off early investors including
paramount paving the way for Netflix to
step in and basically save the day big
business and the government they're
trying to pull us down along with the
high cost of using cgi d aging the look
of it can also be a bit distracting for
some users on Twitter of made comments
like looks like a cut scene from a ps4
game or the CGI looks terrible
sorry this isn't the Lion King it's a
Scorsese movie and my personal favorite
why does Robert De Niro look like he's
from the Polar Express why is the Polar
Express animation so creepy
I do want to know that others are
confident that quote there's still lots
of time to fix it and I'm sure paramount
is happy this is no longer their issue
since we're still waiting to see the new
Sonic the Hedgehog guys I know see they
don't know why No
okay so the real interesting thing about
Netflix being the home of the irishman
is that in recent years Scorsese and De
Niro have both expressed how they really
feel about movies being made for digital
streaming with Bob saying quote movies
have to be shown on a big screen at last
year's Marrakesh Film Festival and
Scorsese adding quote the ideal would be
to see cinema in its proper context at a
New York City event last year so it's no
wonder Netflix will put this movie in
theaters which by the way also makes it
eligible for an Academy Award you can't
miss the big picture so can the Irishman
bring a Best Picture Oscar to Netflix's
trophy case to go alongside Roma statues
for directing and foreign language film
well some of the likely competition
looks really strong with movies like ad
astra a beautiful day in the
neighborhood
and Once Upon a Time in Hollywood but
along with Scorsese's directing win for
The Departed the cast is a combined five
Oscars on 19 nomination plus the film
reunites Scorsese with DeNiro Pesci and
Keitel from certified fresh' classics
like Mean Streets taxi driver Raging
Bull Goodfellas and casino then throw in
Al Pacino on top of that and people
thought the MCU had the most iconic cat
I mean an Oscar win does feel promising
here whatever you need me to do I'm
available all right it is time to kick
it over to you now are you excited for
the Irishman will you see it in theaters
or while sitting on your couch are you
worried that the DEA agent will be too
distracting or are you down for the DEA
let us know your thoughts in the
comments section and tell us what other
stories you'd like to see us cover and
for all the latest trailers and movie
news head on over to ron tomatoes calm
thanks for watching our new show the
ketchup where we explore with the latest
news for movies and TV means to you as
always i'm as
and I'm gonna go trying to age myself
now until next time
[Music]